is it just me or is the mustache having
a moment more and more celebrities are
starting to wear just a mustache as a
style statement these days everybody
from Henry caval to Pedro Pascal let's
dissect some of the finest mustaches
that Hollywood has to
[Music]
offer Miles
Teller I'm just going to say it top gun
Maverick put the mustache back on the
map suddenly younger guys were wanting
mustaches because Miles Teller looks
really cool in this and his mustache
here was just a nod back to the original
film with Anthony Edwards who had the
same mustache my dad had a mustache when
I was growing up and I remember the
first time I ever saw him without one I
almost didn't recognize him because his
upper lip looked huge I kind of think
that's what's going on with Miles Teller
here I've gotten so used to seeing him
with a mustache that without a mustache
I can't stop staring at his upper lip
one of the things I like about Miles
Teller with a mustache is it just makes
him look more mature with this kind of
shape I think he was trying to go for a
bit of a chef but I'm not sure if he has
the growth that's okay if you can't grow
the mustache of your dreams you can
still probably grow something and it can
still look cool you don't always have to
get all the way there but I think
whatever this is it works really great
on milest Teller I mean is it just me or
is this giving you kind of Tom celic
Magnum PI Vibes if you look at Miles
teller's looking Top Gun this has a
direct correlation to Magnum PI which of
course is another mustache hero from the
1980s it was essentially a good time guy
that paired up with a floral shirt and
gave him this sort of sex appeal I'm not
sure what's doing that heavy lifting
here the mustache or the floral shirt
either way it's
working Henry
caval straight out of the gate I'm going
to say that Henry Cowell looks a lot
better with a mustache than without a
mustache it adds some interesting kind
of articulated definition to his face
Henry kev's mustache actually started a
small revolution in what we call the
beard stash it's basically when you pair
up a mustache with very short stubble
which kind of decreases the contrast and
makes it a better entry level mustache
for guys that are maybe feeling a little
selfcon conscious about just having the
old lip caterpillar up there but what's
most interesting about this mustache is
it is a multi-million doll mustache when
he was doing re-shoot for the Justice
League he was simultaneously filming
Mission Impossible a film in which he
had a mustache so when he had to go back
and do the re-shoot they asked him to
shave it off but the studio said no
instead they had to digitally remove his
mustache from the film to the tune of
over $20 million that's some serious
commitment to the stash now the shape of
Henry Cav's mustache here is called a
Chevron that's two sending Square shapes
one on either side of the nostrils this
shape is worn by lots of people like
Donald
Glover you can see here Donald Glover is
also wearing nicely shaped stubbles so
this is an excellent representation of a
beard stash one of the things that's
really great about a Chevron mustache is
it pairs up really nicely with a square
angular jaw you can see how much it
amplifies the square shape of the jaw
and really highlights the better
features of his face this is a very
flattering look for Donald Glover both
these celebrities have nice strong jaws
and so pairing it up with an angular
looking nicely outlined mustache will
complement that perfectly his mustache
chef's
kiss Pedro
Pascal Pedro Pascal is one of those
actors that can wear a lot of different
facial hair but I really love to see him
with something not nothing I almost
don't recognize him without some sort of
like scraggly beard or some sort of
outlined mustache and his mustache style
is kind of a version of a Chevron but
has these like dropping corners on the
side of his mouth that makes it feel a
little bit more like an outlaw and I
really like that Vibe sometimes he wears
it with a little bit of a beard stash
but his Beard's not particularly thick
in fact a lot of people have given him a
lot of flak that he doesn't grow a thick
enough beard honestly give the man a
break he is a National Treasure when it
comes to his overall style I love this
dropping style of mustache on him it
does have that kind of badass bikery
Outlaw Vibe and you can't really talk
about Outlaws and mustaches without
mentioning the original Outlaw mustache
Mr B
Reynolds now Bert Reynolds was an
American actor and he was in a ton of
movies but probably one of his most
outstanding roles was Smokey and the
Bandit he had this cool Cowboy Vibe with
this little pyramid mustache and this
Swagger and the style that really worked
Bert Reynolds is one of those guys
that's always worn stash prominently so
you don't often see him less than maybe
clean shaven with a very solid
contrasting mustache and he's worn
everything from a tight little pyramid
to a heavier Chevron and really the
difference between those two is the Top
Line the top line of a Chevron mustache
is very nice and square to the lip
whereas a pyramid descends slightly into
points towards the outside it gives a
bit of a different effect and a
different feature to his face but I
think he looks good with everything
Jesus this guy even looks good clean
shaven grooming tip number 55 learn to
use a safety razor it's cooler than a
cartridge it's close as a straight razor
and the blades are as cheap as chips it
was good enough for Grandpa and His
Hands shook like a washing machine with
a full load one of the reasons I think
it's it's great to be able to compare
these two is because Pedro Pascal and
Bert Reynolds have very similar face
shapes and features so it makes sense
that those mustache shapes would work
equally on both of
them Jim
Carrey Jim Carrey is a character that
we're not used to seeing with just a
mustache but for his role in Sonic the
Hedgehog he started off in the first
episode with what we call a handlebar
mustache now a handlebar mustache
actually turns up at the ends it's
fashioned after an oldfashioned
handlebar on a bike in fact if you want
to know what handlebar mustache is
defined as the English handlebar
mustache club which was established in
the 1800s defines it as and I quote a
herit appendage of the upper lip with
graspable extremities which is about the
most English thing I've ever heard fun
fact about Sonic 2 I was Jim's Barber on
that movie and I worked with Jim and
that mustache it's not real a lot of
those types of mustaches are very
difficult to achieve yourself and create
such a low amount of functionality that
it would be almost impossible to
maintain one in real life a lot of the
time that's either going to be some sort
of exaggerated makeup or CGI and in this
case it was both so hoping to grow a
mustache like this yourself is going to
take a pretty big commitment either way
I think we'll agree that the handlebar
mustache suits him just a little bit
better than that Mustachio monstrosity
the important part to understand about a
handlebar mustache is that there's two
parts to everybody's mustache there's
the peak and the points the points are
usually the longer part and the peak is
kept a little bit shorter and more
sculpted so that the mouth maintains its
functionality if you want to wear your
points up it's about taking a blow dryer
creating just a little bit of shape and
then using a wax to maintain that nice
clean facade you don't necessarily need
to go with a heavy wax style either you
can look at Tom Hardy in the film
Bronson he had a similar style mustache
that was worn just a little looser
without the kind of producted pointy
tips it still has a cool feel to it and
looks a little less high maintenance and
honestly pretty
badass Bad
Bunny I honestly love this guy he's so
charismatic and he's so interesting in
fun to watch and he has so much fun with
his style but one of the things that
really stood out to me here is that
there's a lot of guys that are starting
to wear this shape called the half
horseshoe which is something that he is
sporting perfectly now horseshoe shape
is often misconstrued as a handlebar
mustache in fact a lot of people call it
a handlebar mustache but this shape
around the mouth that drops to the sides
is actually called a horseshoe mustache
and the most modern iteration of that is
where a lot of guys are wearing what we
call a half horseshoe which means the
sidelines don't drop all the way to the
chin they just come below the corners of
the mouth now I think this is is
actually a really cool look it looks
very badass and cowboy and has again a
bit of an outlaw feel in fact anytime
you see a mustache dropping to the sides
past the corners of the mouth gives it a
little bit more of a Rough and Ready
kind of feel to it I really dig it and
it looks really great on him here
especially cuz he contrasts this against
wearing a beard as well which is nice
and finely outlined so this is a guy
that is clearly no stranger to spending
time on his grooming his beard is always
neatly outlined his half horseshoe is
always neatly outlined this is a very
cool style other guys like to wear stuff
like like this are the
weekend you can see on the weekend same
style it just drops slowly to the
outside and gives it a little bit more
of a retro badass Vibe you can contrast
that against the type of facial hair he
wears which is always neatly outlined
these are guys that are no stranger to
having a decent beard trimmer and
something that can maintain those
outlines every single day I think a
certain amount of badassery is assigned
to this mustache because of guys like
Danny tro who's been wearing this thing
for as long as I can remember and is
clear not to be with but if you
want to wear something just a little bit
more out there and really go for it I
say go all the way man go Hulk Hogan on
it that guy's Sidelines drop all the way
down to his collar bone yeah brother now
even though this type of mustache
usually does require a little bit more
solid growth especially where your
mustache connects to the rest of your
beard that little corner part there if
that grows solid down then you're good
it's still really good option even if
you can't grow a full beard grooming tip
number 29 always try and shave with the
G grain of your beard Against the Grain
will be closer but it's also a recipe
for ingrown hairs and
irritation Nick
Offerman honestly I mean is there a more
masculine representation in history than
Ron Swanson but if you ask me the
mustache is doing the heavy lifting for
the character there's something really
solid about a walrus style mustache that
he's wearing here now the walrus style
mustache covers both lips so it really
obscures most of the mouth this is a
very bold mustach to wear it is
something that has low functionality
because it covers the mouth so there's a
bit of a commitment that it takes but
that's kind of the beauty of it it's the
fact that that mustache is so present
and so forward that it's almost
distracting from the rest of the
features altogether now if you look side
by side I think Nick Offerman looks a
lot better with a mustache than without
a mustache maybe I'm just partial to
that whole Ron Swanson thing the thing
is mustache isn't just a aesthetic it's
kind of a Vibe as well and different
mustaches seem to be making their way
into different shows and films and they
almost enhance the quality of the
character that's wearing them look at
Ted lasso Ted lasso made mustaches
pretty cool again especially if you're
got kind of a friendly Vibe but if you
go back a few years before that you'll
find movies like anchor man where the
mustache really signified Ron's
arrogance there was something so funny
about Ron's mustache it was just such
comic relief and the way he would like
wiggle it and make it kind of dance and
stuff and with a more contemporary
version of that being seen on Ted lasso
you can really see like that heaviness
of the mustache almost creates a a kind
of more friendly vage to it but look at
other guys that have worn a walrus
mustache like Sam
Elliott now Sam Elliott is my personal
mustache hero that guy has embodied what
it is to have a cool mustache and if you
see him without one it almost looks kind
of weird when it comes to the walrus
mustache the whole purpose of it is that
length and that growth so it doesn't
require an awful lot of Maintenance and
grooming but it will require an awful
lot of napkins and an awful lot of fine
motor skills when it comes to actually
eating drinking the wall mustache is
kind of notorious for being difficult to
work with I actually just think it's
cool that it's named after an animal
other mustaches that are named after
animals is of course the capy Bara
mustache which is owned solely by post
Malone whose mustache looks like two
capy baras
kissing I know I can't unsee it either a
slightly similar but more groomed style
of this can be found on actor Milos
filia if I'm being honest I think he
looks better without a mustache maybe
it's the rest of his outfit but he kind
of looks like like a silent movie star
like the villain as much as that can be
cool I think he just looks a little more
stoic and badass without one a mustache
to me doesn't look natural on him it
almost looks like a costume sometimes
that's important does your mustache fit
the rest of your style or does it stick
out like a sore thumb sometimes we got
to take that into
account Michael
Sarah now I know Michael Sarah's a bit
of a Darkhorse choice for this list but
there's actually a reason I chose to
talk about him Michael Sarah has a round
face shape mustaches are not always the
most flattering thing for guys with a
round face shape that mustache that he
has just makes his face look even wider
now let's compare that against somebody
else that has a round face shape Michael
B Jordan he has a round face shape and a
mustache the difference is he wears what
we call an anchored stash that means he
has a small goatee at the bottom which
really draws out the shape of the chin
and leans out the face shape creating a
better sense of balance for a look like
this to see Michael B Jordan without
facial hair absolutely Works he doesn't
need it but if I'm being honest I think
he looks pretty good with it I'm going
to say with facial
hair Brad
Pit When Brad Pit wore this mustache
style for the engl glorious bastards
film it really evoked an old style
Hollywood kind of vibe it was right
around the time when everybody was
wearing these really cool classic
haircuts and so it really fit right in
he's wearing a style called a pencil
style now a pencil style is not just a
thin little squiggly line above the
upper lip that makes you look like a
French waiter with the pencil mustache
both the peak and the points are kept
very very short his is more of a thicker
classic pen pencil mustache he's wearing
what we call a full pencil style and
it's really cool I think he looks great
with a mustache I don't however think he
looks great with a beard so this is one
of those face shapes or maybe just one
of those personalities that in all
honesty works really really great with
this type of facial hair it adds just a
little bit of interest to his face
without completely obscuring the rest of
his face the way a beard often does now
other representations of pencil
mustaches are of course guys like John
Waters who is that super thin little
pencil mustache in fact many people
refer this mustache as the John Waters
mustache but also Eddie Murphy who wore
this mustache a lot during the 80s and
90s and as you can see he has that
little anchor at the bottom of it which
really balances out the rest of the
shape being as his face shape is already
quite lean looks really sharp but
there's another famous mustache that's
based on the pencil mustache that was
made famous by artist Salvador Dolly now
the dolly mustache is essentially a
pencil mustache with very long points
that are waxed up into tips in
subcultures of the mustache world
there's actually competitions to see who
has the best versions of must mustaches
like these my God look at that thing
you're going to put an eye out with that
a pencil mustache is something that
requires an awful lot of Maintenance
it's something you have to be on top of
almost constantly because as soon as it
gets a little bit bushy it starts to
lose its shape so having a really good
mustache trimmer for a shape like this
is Paramount grooming tip number 212
change your razor cartridge frequently
it'll help you avoid unsightly razor
rash and ingrown
hairs Timothy
shalam Timothy shalam is still young guy
and he has something that I like to call
the shadow stash it's kind of that pre-
mustache move but there is still
something kind of cool about it now the
shadow stash gives you just this elusive
little idea of a pencil mustache and
makes him feel just a little bit more
European almost but when it comes to
your overall grooming a shadow stash is
fine he probably is going to look best
clean shaven there's no point in
amplifying the jaw if it's already
chiseled and perfect and look at that
thing other actors that have trouble
growing thicker facial hair guys like
Steven Yuan also Rock a similar style of
mustach
here one of the things I like about the
way Steve Yuan does it is again he
creates the anchor style he has a little
bit of that goatee at the bottom which
really amplifies the shape of his chin
and draws out the more linear shape of
his face thanks for tuning in to our
Deep dive into Hollywood's finest
mustaches the coolest thing about
mustaches is that almost everyone can
grow some type of mustache even though
you might not be able to grow a full
beard or have patchy areas or you're not
as dense as you'd like to be you can
still probably have some sort of
mustache style now I hope there was some
inspiration in here for you to find a
style that might work for you got
someone you think should have been on
this list make sure you drop a comment
below and let us know maybe we'll put
them into part two my name is Maddie
Conrad and until next time good luck and
good
[Music]
grooming